gut gemeint ist noch lange nicht gut
gemacht
einsatz für alle lebenslagen auch für
eine impfkampagne die gegen korona und
alle arbeiten erst mal auf eigene
rechnung bund länder europa
pharmaindustrie wie man es in einer
ernsten lage eben nicht machen sollte
die impfstoff misere wie kommen wir da
wieder raus jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studium anders
sauerbrei ist bei uns mitglied der
chefredaktion des berliner tagesspiegels
und sie leitet dort das ressort meinung
und causa causa steht für die rubrik
debatten seite in der zeitung
hans-georg feldmeier ist vorsitzender
des bundesverbandes der pharmazeutischen
industrie und sie sind auch gleichzeitig
vorstandsvorsitzender von der mav arm
der dermatologie
das ist insofern wichtig dass ein
impfstoffhersteller und sie sind auch
mit biontech unternehmerisch verbunden
zugeschaltet ist wolfgang kaiser er
betreibt eine hausarztpraxis in berlin
zehlendorf und sie sind gleichzeitig
vorsitzender des hausärzteverbandes
berlin-brandenburg und schließlich
stephan pusch und der cdu cdu mitglied
er ist landrat im landkreis heinsberg im
äußersten westen der republik und dieser
landkreis wurde vor ziemlich genau einem
jahr bekannt als erster richtiger krone
hotspot in nordrhein westfalen vor
sauerbrei gipfel so nannte man das ja
gestern das klingt so ein bisschen
global und bedeutend wie ist denn der
gestrige ins gipfel einzuschätzen
daher häufig wenn das wort gipfel oder
sogar nationaler impfgipfel jetzt
gebraucht wird dann wollen vor allen
dingen politiker signalisieren dass sie
ein thema sehr ernst nehmen dann geht es
viel darum ein symbol zu setzen ein
zeichen zu setzen
die ergebnisse waren jetzt erwarten aber
immerhin man hat sich einmal an einen
tisch gesetzt sich noch einmal
ausgetauscht und es gab ja auch einiges
an politischer unruhe einzufangen
da fällt man ja gibt es jetzt nach dem
gestrigen gipfel mehr pharmaindustrie
verstehe in der politik ich hoffe das
sehr
ich hoffe auch sehr dass irgendwann
sendung nicht mehr mit den begriffen im
misere und grundsätzlich negativ
eingeleitet werden ich finde das haben
wir alle nicht verdient und insofern
teile ich sehr stark ihre hoffnung dass
wir hier eine wende auch in der
diskussion bekommen
wer ist denn für die impfen die serie
verantwortlich
wenn sie jetzt sagen dass eigentlich ein
begriff der eben nicht so passt ist dass
die politik sind das alle zusammen
gewesen ich finde das wort im knie serie
schon falsch und ist eigentlich einen
nicht 1 1 1 1 über kein guter begriff
gerade in gegenwart und auch für die
vielen menschen die sich hier ungeheuer
engagieren in politik in den
verwaltungen in den pharmazeutischen
betrieben die täglich wirklich großes
leisten vielleicht ist manchmal nicht
alles so gelungen wie sich die
allgemeinheit vorstellt und vielleicht
würden wir einiges auch gerne vielleicht
noch schneller und noch besser haben
wollen aber dennoch finde ich es wichtig
wenn wir auch darauf achten welche
wörter wir zur beschreibung der
gegenwärtigen situation wenn du das tun
wir auch nur in serie haben natürlich
auch deswegen weil die allgemeinheit
haben sie jetzt freundlicher weise schon
angesprochen möglicherweise das so
empfindet jedenfalls teile oder die
enttäuscht sind wie das jetzt angelaufen
ist aber dass werden in der sendung noch
weiter vertiefen herrscher sind die
ärzte nach dem gestrigen tag nach diesem
gipfel im kanzleramt schlauer als zuvor
natürlich nicht es gibt viele offene
fragen das ist klar
man muss sagen die lage ist angespannt
die nerven sind auch angespannt liegen
teilweise blank es ist vieles passiert
vieles ist gut gelaufen ich kann
vielleicht ein paar beispiele print aber
es sind viele offene fragen und wir
müssen untereinander alle akteure müssen
besser kommunizieren besser miteinander
reden und aufeinander hören
sie haben ja die bundesregierung in den
letzten tag auch massiv kritisiert für
das was da abgelaufen ist bisher mit den
vorbereitungen wie sich das dann auf der
kommunalen ebene auch darstellt sind
denn ihre anliegen die sie da
vorgetragen haben die ja viele ihrer
kolleginnen und kollegen auch vortragen
sind die denn gestern in berlin erhört
worden also das kann man jetzt
eigentlich nicht direkt sagen also das
wird ja gerade schon mal fazit gezogen
was hat dieser gipfel eigentlich
gebracht ich hätte mir von dem gipfel
gewünscht dass man mal klar sagt
es hätte besser laufen können
insbesondere bei der impfstoff
beschaffung und wir haben vor
weihnachten erwartungen geweckt bei der
bevölkerung die wir nicht einhalten
können punkt ja dass man muss glaube ich
zwei kreise auseinanderhalten das eine
ist dass wir natürlich nach vorne gucken
müssen und dass kritik ja auch immer
konstruktiv sein sollte und über
verschüttete milch man hier im rheinland
sagt ständig streiten noch jetzt wochen
monate lang bringt uns natürlich in der
sache keinen deut nach vorne bringt uns
keiner einzigen ampulle impfstoff an den
mann oder an die frau
aber ich finde zu einem guten krisen
management gehört auch dazu dass man
sich zwischendurch immer mal wieder
ehrlich macht und wir haben natürlich
hier auf der kommunalen ebene die
landkreise die kreisfreien städte den
unwillen der bürger ganz massiv in
unserem bürgertelefon erlebt wie ihr
mann hat sich bei uns beschwert das war
nicht nur die die frage natürlich
letztendlich an dem nicht so zur
verfügung stehen und impfstoff hin wie
wie das quasi angekündigt war
das war das eine problem der die
technische umsetzung der terminvergabe
war das zweite problem
und auch wenn man da überhaupt nicht
eingebunden ist als kommunaler seite ist
man ja sehr nah an der basis und wenn
die bürger bei der 116 117 nicht
durchkommen dann landen die im
bürgertelefon des kreises heinsberg und
ich habe ja deswegen auch massiv mal
laut gegeben weil ich mich auch für
meine mitarbeiter stellen musste denn
die haben hier von herzzerreißenden
weinen über böse wutanfälle bis hin zu
dem statement wir hängen den landrat
jetzt vor der kreisverwaltung auf der
iss damit für verantwortlich erzählt ist
doch nix der hat uns mit dem minister
zusammen angeschrieben
da musste ich mich einfach mal für die
mitarbeiter stellen dass daraus
natürlich dann in einem in einem video
auch das rauskommt was ich was sich den
letzten wochen so an frust aufgebaut hat
das ist natürlich auch klar und insofern
war der gipfel gestern was dieses sag
ich mal was die manöverkritik angeht
nicht zielführend gut fand ich
allerdings man soll ja nicht immer nur
mit dem finger auf andere zeigt gut fand
ich allerdings dass man zumindest mal
deutlich machte wir machen das jetzt
wieder zu einer angelegenheit von
nationaler wichtigkeit wir haben an alle
beteiligten an einen tisch gebracht und
es sind ja durchaus auch ein paar
zusagen in die zukunft getroffen worden
die wieder vertrauen bei der bevölkerung
aufbauen müssen denn ich glaube von imf
misere würde ich auch nicht reden aber
es hätte deutlich besser gehen können
als wir das jetzt haben jetzt bringt
natürlich auch nicht ständig zu jammern
sondern wir müssen gemeinsam und da
bieten wir natürlich auch die kommunale
seite ihre hilfe an
nach vorne gucken denn man muss die
ambition und den willen und die energie
die die alle ins statische neben jetzt
nach einstecken von dem unterscheiden
was bisher eigentlich hätte besser
laufen können und dass die briten sich
jetzt über uns kaputt lachen ist schon
traurig muss ich sagen wir haben ja
jetzt will ich sie ganz kurz
unterbrechen
jetzt ist sie auch ein bisschen länger
reden lassen weil gerade die kommunale
ebene ja dann oft dies ausbaden müssen
die in berlin oder von berlin aus
übersehen werden wir werden das ja auch
gleich alles noch vertiefen wir wollen
jetzt hier auch keine gefechte in der
vergangenheit führen aber eine frage
trotzdem noch vor sommer 3 man hat ja
gesagt dieser impfgipfel sei viel zu
spät einberufen worden war das so hätte
man das schon viel früher machen müssen
weil das was wir mit serie jetzt im
titel genannt haben was der feldmeier
oder auch herr bush nicht so sehr als
misere sehen
das war ja eigentlich schon vorher
abzusehen ist das sind ja da ein
bisschen weil ist die politik da ein
bisschen später
ich weiß gar nicht also vielleicht war
es ein bisschen zu spät um eben diesen
unmut abzufangen man hätte vielleicht
früher moderierend in die debatte
eingreifen können aber ich glaube in der
sache ändert der zeitpunkt ja nichts in
der sache ist die entscheidung der
europäischen union das die verträge so
abzuschließen wie sie abgeschlossen
wurden
die ist schon im vergangenen jahr
gefallen und daraus ergibt sich dass
weitere eben die liefermengen die jetzt
zur verfügung stehen können und das
jetzt eben bestimmte unternehmen die die
impfstoffe herstellen nicht schnell
genug die erwartete anzahl liefern
können und ich glaube an diesen kern
faktum aus dem sie alles weitere ergibt
ändert sich ja nichts
ob man den gipfel jetzt zwei wochen
früher oder später machen könnte also
wie gesagt ich glaube man hätte das
friedensangebot und die befriedung
bisschen früher machen können aber
nichts an der sache
man es geht ja vor allen dingen darum
dass jetzt möglichst schnell genügend
impfstoff da es um möglichst viele
menschen zu impfen
das stimmt den corinna virus ein soll
auch schützen möglicherweise für eine
längere zeit auf dauer oder es muss
öfter nach games sie hatten wie auch
immer wenn man sich aber jetzt die
gestrige das gestrige gesprächsergebnis
ansieht haben manche gesagt da hat der
berg gekreist und hat einen mann geboren
ist das eine zu harte kritik für das was
da gestern raus gekommen ist oder weil
die erwartungshaltungen einfach zu hoch
also dieses gremium gestern hat sich ja
selber nicht den titel impfgipfel
gegeben das wissen wir dass hat das ist
ein medialer politiker dabei da gibt man
dann oft erlebt man so ein begriff da
gibt's ja ich glaube es ist wichtig zu
betonen dass es bereits in der
vergangenheit auch immer schon einen
sehr intensiven dialog natürlich
zwischen bund und ländern gegeben hat zu
dieser thematik also diese diskussion
hat nicht erst gestern begonnen das
denke ich sollten wir alle wissen wir
sollten auch alle wissen das natürlich
auch in der vergangenheit schon ein sehr
intensiver dialog zwischen
beispielsweise der pharmazeutischen
industrie und nicht nur der
pharmaindustrie natürlich auch mit allen
anderen beteiligten und der politik
erfolgt ist um nachfragen gesucht wurde
wie schnell kommen wir hier eigentlich
wie vor an ich glaube es ist das
passiert was auch verständlich ist
nach dieser euphorie das so unglaublich
schnell nach so kurzer zeit tatsächlich
eine zulassung für impfstoff erteilt
werden konnte war die erwartung so groß
dass jetzt mit einmal impfdosen in
unglaublichen mengen sofort verfügbar
sind
ich glaube mit dieser erwartung sind wir
in einer ganz entscheidenden phase
falsche umgegangen
und das sollte uns auch denke ich eine
lehre für die zukunft sein wie wir mit
solchen dingen umgehen
wir haben eigentlich etwas fantastisches
erreicht auf dieser welt innerhalb
kürzester zeit ein impfstoff zur
verfügung zu stellen
und wir haben es sogar geschafft bereits
vor zulassung sehr viele impfdosen zur
verfügung zu stellen um sofort beginnen
zu können
nach einem und da kann man auch wieder
diskutieren ob die eine gruppe besser
rein gehört oder nicht reingehört aber
nach einem impfprogramm mit dem sich
experten beschäftigt haben und nach
besten wissen und gewissen etwas
aufgebaut man ja sagen das eine ist die
entwicklung des impfstoffes das andere
ist wie der impfstoff verabreicht wird
herr kaiser ist das ist das auch ihr
eindruck durch diese rasante entwicklung
bei der impfstoffentwicklung die er
viele überrascht hat dass möglicherweise
die erwartungshaltung dazu hoch war das
jetzt alles andere auch schnell geht
oder haben da möglicherweise politiker
die falschen erwartungen geweckt oder
journalisten oder schon ist sich der
politik heraus
wir nehmen ja nur auf was die politiker
sagen sagen alle erwarten ja jetzt das
was passiert aber wir müssten eigentlich
die diskussion an einer ganz anderen
stelle aufgreifen und zwar stellt sich
doch die frage wollen wir dieses problem
national lösen oder wollen wir es global
lösen weil wenn man das problem global
lösen lösen möchte dann müsste ja der
impfstoff gerade in anderen ländern viel
mehr verändert werden aber
offensichtlich tendiert man jetzt dahin
dass man das national oder europäisch
gelöst und dann ist es natürlich so dass
erwartung geweckt wurden die jetzt so
schnell nicht befriedigt werden können
das muss man einfach mal sagen und der
teufel steckt im detail
es läuft natürlich nicht alles rund da
kann ich 1000 beispiele bringen
aber man muss doch das große ganze sehen
die tatsache ist dass wir jetzt eine
zulassung haben dass wir weitere
impfstoffe in der pipeline haben und
dass wir eigentlich jetzt auf einem
guten weg sind auch wenn es mal da und
dort noch knirscht aber im großen und
ganzen möchte ich mal sagen läuft es
doch relativ gut dass unzufriedenheit
ist in der bevölkerung das sehe ich
jeden tag in der praxis keine ich habe
hier serviererin dafür kurz ein haken
damit nicht der eindruck entsteht die
medien würden nur berichten dass es
hinten und vorne nicht reicht wie ist
denn aus ihrer eigenen praxis in der
hausarztpraxis wie ist es denn da haben
sie gibt es denn da auch und
zufriedenheit erwartungshaltungen werden
sie da auch mal angeraunzt
wo ist eigentlich mein impfstoff ich
erlebt alles ich erlebt patienten die
nicht geimpft werden wollen und von mir
eine bestätigung haben wollen dass sie
geimpft sind
da das ist das eine extrem nicht erlebt
patienten die den impfstoff wollen
gesunde 40 jährige die mit die sagen sie
werden chronisch krank weil sie
vielleicht ein allergisches asthma haben
oder allergischen schnupfen und an den
impfstoff unbedingt dran wollen also es
ist natürlich so wir haben einen mangel
an impfstoff und eine mangelwirtschaft
führt immer zu solchen komischen sachen
zu solchen auswüchsen das gab es in
allen systemen wo es mangel gab in der
früheren ddr gab es das zum beispiel und
das ist im moment beim impfstoff der
fall
die bevölkerung driftet auch ein
bisschen auseinander es gibt ja und es
gibt natürlich ängstliche leute ich habe
leute dieses amt seit mehreren monaten
die wohnung nicht mehr verlassen das
muss man sich mal vorstellen
die lassen sich das essen von den
kindern vor die tür stellen weil sie
angst haben sich an corona zu infizieren
die waren natürlich dringend auf den
impfstoff weil sie dann glauben sie
seien in einer sicherheit was übrig sind
aber dazu kommen wir vielleicht später
was die medien jetzt nochmal angeht weil
er feldmeier das ja auch gerade
angesprochen hat die politiker nutzen ja
auch diese medien um daneben
erwartungshaltungen auch zu wecken wenn
man jetzt mal das was in den letzten
wochen passiert ist gab ja auch
versprechungen des
bundesgesundheitsministers sogar im
verlaufe des sommers als noch im zweiten
quartal könne man allen ein angebot
machen das hat er jetzt zurück genommen
sind wir da auch deswegen im moment in
der schwierigen situation einer
politiker auch in einer schwierigen
situation weil eben auch wahljahr ist
wir haben die bundestagswahl wir haben
auch wichtige landtagswahlen die
politiker politikerinnen und politiker
wollen alle im amt bleiben ist was
spielt das rein
ja absolut also die politische
interessen lage ist natürlich auch
extrem angespannt jetzt mit dem
beginnenden bundestagswahlkampf ich
meine das beginnt
mit den überschneidungen zwischen
politik und und sache der sache beginnt
auf der europäischen ebene wo wir ursula
von der leyen haben die als
kommissionspräsidentin glänzen möchte
die deswegen alles getan hat um die
entscheidung und den einkauf in brüssel
zu ziehen vielleicht auch zurecht ich
möchte das gar nicht kritisieren aber
natürlich ist es auch mit ihrer person
verbunden und mit ihrem ziel wie sie
sich darstellen möchte es geht weiter
mit jens spahn der jetzt nicht cdu
vorstands vorsitzender geworden ist aber
natürlich da extrem hohe ambitionen hat
und sich selbst auch als möglicher
kanzlerkandidat wahrscheinlich immer
noch sieht und es geht weiter mit
länderchefs sie sich profilieren wollen
wir hatten jetzt am wochenende eine
content die konzertierte kritik auch zum
ersten mal aus der spd sogar olaf scholz
der vizekanzler der eigentlich mitglied
des kabinetts ist und auch diese
entscheidungen und und zumindest die
nationale politik mit trägt hat auf
einmal sich vorsichtig angefangen zu
distanzieren von der strategie in den
ländern von manuela schwesig aus
mecklenburg vorpommern kam es viel
heftigere kritik also da merken wir
dieses stillhalteabkommen in der politik
was wir im ersten lockdown hatten das
ist jetzt vorbei wir gehen auf die wahl
zu und angela merkel hat gesagt bis zum
21 september kurz vor der bundestagswahl
soll jeder impfangebot bekommen haben
das wird natürlich den wahlkampf prägen
das wollen wir morgen auch noch ein
bisschen weiter vertiefen der phoenix
runde heute geht es ja vor allem um die
impfstrategie aber ja pushen eine ganz
kurze frage da bitte um die relativ
kurze antwort zu diesem thema noch sie
sind ja auch cdu-politiker sie stellt
sich auch zur wahl bei der kommunalwahl
in nrw die findet dieses jahr nicht
statt aber ihre parteifreunde in
verschiedenen bundesländern und in enns
und längsten spitze längst tschuldigung
der nächste bugatti ganz falsch
informiert kommunalwahl ist dies ja noch
das fall nicht die war letztes jahr habe
ich ja gesagt in dieses jahr und ich bin
schon da haben sie mich falsch
verstanden und ich hab gesagt dieses
jahr sind sie nicht wie im wahlkampf
aber partei kolleginnen und kollegen von
ihnen in anderen bundesländern bei der
bundestagswahl ist dass ein problem
dieser parteipolitische aspekt bei der
diskussion wie das jetzt mit dem impfen
am besten vonstatten geht natürlich
denke ich spielte moment auch
parteipolitik ganz erheblich mit rein
also eigentlich müsste sich eine
bundesregierung beschlossen hinstellen
und sagen so das haben wir so und so
verabredet das ist so und so beschlossen
worden
man hört aber sehr viel zwischentöne
selbst in der cdu csu war ja erst
gestern so ein bisschen der schwerpunkt
der söder sagte irgendwo in einem
nebensatz fand ich sehr aufschlussreich
ja wir müssen jetzt nach vorne schauen
auch wenn das spät dran sind
während kanzlerin und herr spanier
vehement verteidigt haben dass man sich
in der impfstoff beschaffung eigentlich
nichts vorzuwerfen habe
also das sind schon nuance und finde ich
auch innerhalb der cdu csu die da eine
rolle spielen aber ich glaube dass alle
im moment jedenfalls ich hoffe dass das
so bleibt so verantwortungsvoll sind
dass man parteipolitik bei diesem thema
wirklich beiseite legt denn das sollte
da überhaupt keine rolle spielen
ich glaube dafür ist die verantwortung
und die krise auch viel zu groß um jetzt
da noch parteipolitische spielchen zu
betreiben also das finde ich ganz
schlimm
und vielleicht ist meine kritik ja auch
deswegen mehr angenommen worden oder
auch vielleicht mehr auf mehr widerhall
gestoßen weil es ist natürlich viel
einfacher auf den politischen gegner
umzuhauen als den eigenen parteifreunden
mal was zu sagen aber ich finde wir
schulden den menschen brutale
ehrlichkeit das habe ich auch hier im
frühjahr in der ersten phase der
pandemie im kreis heinsberg so
praktiziert weil nur dann kriegen wir
die menschen auf dauer mitgenommen
sowohl bei der imf willigkeit wie auch
bei den sonstigen maßnahmen die wir ja
dringend vor ort zur eindämmung der
pandemie brauchen diese menschen geht
das nicht totale ehrlichkeit das gehört
natürlich auch dazu zu fragen
man kann oder zu sagen dass
produktionsanlagen nicht einfach
herbeigezaubert werden können das dauert
eine zeit lang ein halbes jahr glaube
ich bis ein partnerunternehmen das einem
pharmakonzern hilft bei der produktion
dann auch tatsächlich einsatzbereit ist
das haben wir jetzt den letzten tagen
auch gesehen dass die firma hoechst ja
auch entschieden die firma bayer ja auch
für weg unterstützen will
produktionsanlagen kann man nicht
herbeizaubern aber könnte es doch noch
schneller gehen was ist auch immer ein
latenter vorwurf lehrer an die
pharmaindustrie erhoben wird also das
war natürlich gestern das geeignete
forum das zu diskutieren und auch sehr
offen und sehr ehrlich zu diskutieren
ich glaube ein großer teil des das geld
der gestrigen gespräche zielte ja genau
auf diese fragen ab
die bundesregierung alle
ministerpräsidenten ich glaube alle
verantwortlichen verfolgen mit großer
intensität was gerade passiert und
stellen immer wieder die gleiche frage
an die industrie wie können wir etwas
beschleunigen die gleiche frage die die
menschen natürlich auch an stellen wie
gelingt es uns noch schneller im stoff
zu bekommen hatten geld denn
beschleunigt in der gestrigen diskussion
sind alle firmenchefs zu wort gekommen
die im moment entweder schon impfstoffe
produzieren oder an deren entwicklung
teilnehmen
zugleich auch die vertreter der verbände
der pharmazeutischen industrie
die einhellige antwort aller unternehmer
ist gewesen mit geld kann man hier
nichts beschleunigen warum ist das so
erstens und das ist glaube ich sehr
wichtig dass noch mal festzuhalten
die pharmazeutische industrie hat in den
letzten wochen und monaten schon längst
ohne öffentliche aufmerksamkeit begonnen
riesengroße produktionsnetzwerke
aufzubauen
das ist ganz wichtig dass wir diese
tatsache bitte zur kenntnis nehmen aber
diese dann jetzt so lange gedauert diese
produktionsnetz genau wie sie sagten
eingangs gesagt haben und ihrer frage
formuliert haben der aufbau dieser
produktionsnetzwerke hat schon längst
begonnen und diese produktionsnetzwerke
werden deshalb auch schon erste
ergebnisse ende erstes quartal liefern
was sonst gar nicht möglich wäre sie
sagten selber fünf bis sechs monate das
bezieht sich allein auf die verpackung
und auf das abfüllen von impfstoff die
eigentliche herstellung der chef von
bayer hat es gestern gesagt und ich kann
das bestätigen
braucht circa zwölf monate
vorbereitungszeit selbst bei einem
kompletten know how transfer von einem
unternehmen zum anderen mit
bestmöglicher ganz neidisch auf die usa
oder auf das vereinigte königreich
israel die offensichtlich viel bestellt
haben auch viel geld in die hand
genommen haben mehr haben die müssen ja
die gleichen probleme strukturell haben
in der produktion wo haben die plötzlich
so viel her bekommen
sie haben sie sind etwas früher dran
weil sie früher gestartet haben aber
auch gestern wurde das noch mal
einhellig auch bestätigt dass es sehr
wichtig ist dass die europäische
arzneimittelagentur die ema so heißt die
abkürzung hier sehr gewissenhaft
gearbeitet hat und eine zulassung
erteilt hat die nach vollständiger
prüfung der unterlagen erfolgt ist ich
glaube das ist etwas ganz wichtiges auch
gerade im hinblick auf das was er gesagt
hat weil die menschen brauchen vertrauen
zu diesem impfstoff wir haben bis zur
zulassung dieses impfstoffes immer
wieder die frage gehört von den
patienten und ich bin doch auch dran an
den menschen die gefragt haben der ist
doch viel zu schnell entwickelt worden
der kann doch gar nicht gut sein das ist
doch gar nicht gut für uns da ist er
erinnert das verändert unsere genetische
information
alle diese fragen haben wir versucht so
seriös wie möglich zu beantworten und
auch diese fragen die jetzt hoch kommen
versuchen wir genauso seriös zu
beantworten
er greift wenn jetzt dass dann viele
auch skeptisch sind dass dieser
impfstoff so schnell entwickelt worden
ist was wir jetzt als vorteil empfinden
und sehr viel besser gelaufen als wir
uns das dachten
auf der anderen seite dann dieses
misstrauen was glauben sie denn aus
sicht der hausärzte welche strategie ist
jetzt die die richtige fürs impfen soll
ja auch dann so sein dass viele
hausärzte für impfen und dann auch diese
hohen zahlen für geimpfte zustande
kommen in dem eben die 50.000
hausarztpraxen in deutschland daneben
auch ein impfstoff direkt verabreichen
also zunächst ist es wichtig dass der
jetzige impfstoff denn es gibt in den
impfzentren vererbt wird
gerade auch deshalb weil der tiefgekühlt
werden muss und aus dem anderen grund
weil wir noch einen mangel an impfstoff
haben weil wir können nicht diese
diskussion wer wird geimpft wer wird
priorisiert in die praxen verlagern
wir dürfen erst in den praxen impfen
wenn wir an impfstoff haben der praxis
weg ist der nicht nur tiefgekühlt werden
muss und wenn er in ausreichender menge
vorhanden ist weil ich kann es hier
nicht machen in meiner praxis dass ich
diskutiere wer den impfstoff bekommt und
wer nicht bekommt das heißt die
risikogruppen müssen erstmal
durchgekämpft seien über den mobilen
impf dienst und in den zentren und dann
kann der impfstoff in die hausarztpraxen
ich denke das wird in der mitte des
zweiten quartals seien das
eine einschätzung ob das stimmt wird
sich zeigen aber zu früh sollten kann er
nicht in die praxen das geht gar nicht
das heißt diese 21 september sommerende
herbstanfang den angela merkel da jetzt
analysiert hat das also alle die es
wünschten geimpft zu werden das sind ja
im moment soweit wir das wissen etwa 70
prozent der bevölkerung der ist
realistisch dieser tag dieser stichtag
er natürlich ist der realistisch wir
haben das ja auch geschafft immer den
grippeimpfstoff zu verhelfen
jetzt ist ja das interesse noch viel
größer das heißt wir müssen
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viele
patienten motivieren sich impfen zu
lassen weil die motivation ist ja da bei
den großen bevölkerungsgruppen das sind
vereinzelte die das ablehnen
insofern bin ich sehr zuversichtlich
wenn wir einen praxis fähigen impfstoff
haben dann werden die hausärzte es
schaffen
wir können die grippe impfstoffe
verhelfen wir können auch den corona
impfstoff verenden das werden wir packen
aber wie gesagt die wohl der
rebellengruppen die patienten im
altersheim und so weiter die sollten
jetzt erst mal durch die mobilen impf
teams geimpft werden auch wenn dort
fehler passieren aber im grossen ganzen
ist die strategie richtig
es muss allerdings auch das personal
gleichzeitig geimpft werden
nicht nur das personal auch die
reinigungskräfte und das küchenpersonal
es kann nicht sein dass der impfstoff
nur für die hochbetagten reserviert wird
auch diejenigen die den erreger
reinbringen können die sind ja auch zu
impfen und dazu gehören natürlich das
medizinische personal wie ja auch in
diese gruppe 1 auch rein gehören ein
paar beispiele von impfzentrum bringen
wie es da läuft oder nicht aber das ist
erst mal die richtung in die es gehen
sollte
crossover 3 wenn wir jetzt das alles
hören die impfstoffentwicklung die
ankündigung dann rückschläge diskussion
parteipolitische instrumentalisierung da
gibt es ja unglaublich viele aspekte die
in dieser diskussion jetzt eine rolle
spielen
die sitzen dann mit der kommunikation
aus hat gerade die politik da gut
kommuniziert in dieser frage oder ist da
noch potenzial nach oben da ist auf
jeden fall noch potenzial nach oben ich
glaube was die bürger am meisten
verärgert
wenn das gefühl entsteht hier wird
sozusagen mit wildwest methoden
gearbeitet und auf dem internationalen
markt haben wir moment den eindruck dass
die europäische kommission vielleicht
nicht besonders gut verhandelt hat die
länder die am meisten bezahlt haben die
vielleicht wie israel zusätzlich noch
daten zur verfügung gestellt haben
von also demografische daten über die
geimpften die auf haftungsklauseln
verzichtet haben die waren zuerst dran
und dasselbe sehen wir auch wieder jetzt
was sie ja auch beschrieben haben an der
basis dann werden plattformen geschaltet
wo man sich in online termin besorgen
kann
da werden dann 30.000 termine rhein
gekippt an einem montagmorgen und die
die am schnellsten sind oder halt einen
geschickten enkel haben der mit der
seite umgehen kann und morgen da sitzt
sind immer wieder auf den knopf drückt
die bekommen dann den impftermin und ich
glaube das ist das was so frustrierend
dass ich glaube meine menschen erklärt
und und es gibt ja eine gute erklärung
es gibt eine gute erklärung dafür warum
bestimmte gruppen zuerst geimpft werden
ich bin natürlich als 40 jährige gesunde
person sehr gerne bereit zu warten bis
alle älteren geimpft sind oder alle
risikopatienten und natürlich auch die
mit ihnen umgehen ich glaube das
versteht jeder da gibt es eine ganz
große zustimmung dafür aber es muss auch
erklärt werden und es muss der eindruck
entstehen es läuft geordnet ab und der
ist gerade auch an der basis ist ja
jetzt für die nächste sitzung am 10
februar das ist ja wenn die kanzlerin
mit den ministerpräsidenten wieder
zusammenkommt ja angekündigt worden da
soll ein nationaler impfplan vorgestellt
werden der soll auch ziemlich konkret
seiner folgen dann wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe liefermengen lieferdaten
eingefügt eingearbeitet werden dann nach
all dem was wir bis jetzt erlebt haben
und dass das ja mit vielen unbekannten
in dieser gleichung verbunden ist das
klingt eigentlich eher nach glücksspiel
so ein nationaler impfplan na ja das
können sie erscheinen nun mal besser
erklären aber nach dem was ich jetzt
gelesen hat wird es glaube ich schon
tendenziell die lieferdaten
zuverlässiger wenn die kapazitäten
einmal aufgebaut sind und die
produktionsstätten eingespielt sind das
sind glaube ich jetzt auch so die
kleinen schluck auf die
die diese produktion am anfang hat von
daher würde ich denken dass man schon
verlässlicher wird und das ist natürlich
ganz wichtig für die länder oder eben
auch die kommunen die sich darauf
einstellen müssen in ihren impfzentren
oder dann eben irgendwann vielleicht
auch in den hausarztpraxen nach der
impfung sind sie mit dem begriff
glücksspiel auch nicht so einverstanden
sei richtig ich will nur vorausschicken
zu der frage dass das unsicher ist ja
wir wissen nicht genau welche impfstoffe
noch zugelassen werden wie viel
geliefert werden ob vielleicht einer
anderen firma außer biontech noch
einfällt dass sie ein werk noch umbauen
müssen und deswegen die produktion
zurückfahren wie viel planungssicherheit
ist denn von seiten der
impfstoffindustrie möglich um diesen
nationalen impfplan mit leben zu
erfüllen damit man einige weisen genau
bis zum herbst abschätzen kann wie viel
impfstoff ist da und wie viele menschen
können geimpft werden alle die das ist
ja das versprechen die tatsächlich sich
impfen lassen wollen
es ist ja ein wenig zynisch wenn sie das
sagen dass bei tectum ein feld das noch
etwas umgebaut werden muss kann aber
erst nachdem sie zugesagt haben was sie
zunächst schicken ja also ist es ihnen
offenbar der nasa wir wollen wir den
impfplan reden und vielleicht nicht
nicht zynisch darüber sprechen die firma
biotec ist ja nun die erste die wirklich
mit pfizer mit der kooperation und auch
mit unserem haus beispielsweise in im am
start ist und die größten mengen in
dieser startphase
an impfstoffen tatsächlich liefert und
dafür denke ich können wir alle sehr
dankbar sein das thema impfplan ist
gestern diskutiert worden
ich glaube der terminus impfplan es
gestern auch erstmalig so kreiert worden
warum war das möglich weil letztlich
nach dieser startphase mit völlig neuen
technologien die wir haben völlig neue
technologien die wir aus dem
labormaßstab im produktionsmaßstab
überführen müssen von produktionsmaßstab
in einem werk in das nächste bringen
müssen wir in einer ramp up phase sind
wo wir wo es uns immer leichter fällt
prognosen zu machen
dennoch will ich auch in aller offenheit
so wie es auch gestern sehr offen
diskutiert worden ist sagen das ist bei
all dieser hoffnungsvollen aussicht
dass die ramp up phase gelingt auch
immer noch geringfügige die risiken gibt
die firmen haben davon gesprochen dass
natürlich bestimmte ausgangsmaterialien
diese mit der neuen technologie in
verbindung stehen das wort lipide ist
gefallen und auch medial schon ja
verbreitet worden dass durchaus hier
noch gewisse risiken in der beschaffung
sind und wir im moment alle damit
rechnen dass es den best case verläuft
für das heißt als pharmaindustrie da
unter druck gesetzt dass die politik
jetzt ankündigt da gibt es demnächst
einen nationalen iranischen die leute da
sollen gebratene tauben fliegen und sie
haben dann die verantwortung
ich finde und das ist das wichtige was
gestern auch als botschaft gekommen ist
und das ist auch das was letztlich von
den teilnehmern herausgebracht wurde
wir fühlen uns gemeinsam dafür
verantwortlich und das ist finde ich das
positive signal wir wissen voneinander
dass wir das bestmögliche tun
ich weiß bei mir von mitarbeitern die
doppelschichten fahren ich weiß bei mir
von mitarbeitern die auch nach einer
nach einer verantwortungsvollen
tätigkeit als produktionschef in
beispielsweise nach hause geht und zwei
kindern homeschooling hat auch unsere
menschen betrifft es doch genauso wir
sind genauso von den folgen von corona
beeinflusst wie wir alle wie wir alle
die auf den impfstoff waren
deshalb sollen sie uns bitte nur glauben
dass wir das bestmögliche alle gemeinsam
unternehmen damit dass durch impfen so
schnell wie möglich passiert das heißt
diese einundzwanzigste september steht
jetzt im raum ich nenne ihn selbst wenn
angela merkel herr pusch ihre
parteifreundin jahr mehrfach genannt hat
am ende des sommers also 21
september eine woche vor der
bundestagswahl soll dieses versprechen
eingelöst worden eingelöst werden was
passiert eigentlich wenn das nicht
stattfindet aus welchen gründen auch
immer wenn dieser termin der sowie ein
feiertag jetzt fast schon geheiligt wird
nicht einzuhalten ist
mit dem vertrauensvorschuss sich die
bevölkerung in der politik auch immer
gegeben hat
also ich sag mal wir haben ja erlebt man
sollte aus seinen fehlern lernen dass
auch bewusst oder unbewusst jedenfalls
wir mussten infozentren aus dem boden
stampfen schon im dezember bei der
bevölkerung riesen große
erwartungshaltung entstanden war die man
jetzt enttäuschen musste ich glaube am
seriösesten wäre es jetzt wirklich wenn
man mal mit versprechen sehr vorsichtig
umgeht
denn ob jetzt 21 september ich denke mal
wenn jetzt einige impfstoffe die jetzt
auch noch gar nicht auf dem bildschirm
waren jetzt nicht schnell eine zusage zu
bekommen ich rede jetzt von russischem
impfstoff und anderen dann kann es
natürlich unter umständen alles gut
läuft sogar schneller gehen ich habe
also eigentlich großes vertrauen in die
industrie die leistungsfähigkeit auch
wieso ähnlich wie der impfstoff ja in
rekordgeschwindigkeit entwickelt worden
ist weil natürlich unwahrscheinlicher
druck da war natürlich auch eine
unwahrscheinliche was für die industrie
auch immer wichtig ist gewinnerwartung
dahinter steckte so ist es auch so dass
ich schon vertrauen darin habe dass die
industrie alles tun wird um jetzt die
produktions kapazitäten hochzufahren und
auch einen vernünftigen vernünftige
menge an impfstoff zu liefern aber wir
wissen alle noch nicht was um die ecke
kommt und wir haben doch jetzt einmal
erlebt dass das schlimmste was man den
menschen antun kann
enttäuschte erwartungen sind und
deswegen fände ich es jetzt tatsächlich
auch seriöser zu sagen so wir haben im
moment bestimmte mengen wir können jetzt
mal mittelfristig sagen im ersten
quartal wird es noch knapp seien in zwei
wir noch mehr bekommen aber jetzt eine
prognose bis zum 21 september abzugeben
auch wenn das natürlich ein dilemma der
großen politik ist denn genau diese
aussage erwartet man natürlich von der
großen politik aber wer weiß ob die
impfstoff wenn ich noch angepasst werden
müssen noch irgendwelche mutationen dann
die wirksamkeit herabsetzen noch
irgendwas um die ecke kommt also bei
diesem virus muss ich sagen bei dieser
pandemie haben uns schon viele
überraschungen erreicht und ich glaube
die leute wir uns eher verstehen dass
man sagt wir haben eine gewisse
planungssicherheit wir streben das auch
an
aber dass man das so auf den 21
september kapriziert wird auch er dafür
sorgen dass es politisch dann auch ein
thema wird denn natürlich wird die
opposition versuchen zweifel an dieser
kanzler zusagen zu stören ich kann mir
schon die wahlkampf mottos vorstellen
merkel hat versprochen merkel hat nicht
geliefert das finde ich nicht so
prickelnd steht ja nicht mehr so viel
reisen
wilhelm busch am einem jahr september
ich würde gerne noch mehr weil sie
gerade von enttäuschten erwartungen der
bevölkerung gesprochen habe eine
enttäuschung besteht auch darin dass
diese impftermine angeht es ist ja schon
hier angesprochen worden in der sendung
also 90 jährige die sich im internet im
termin besorgen das wird irgendwie
schwierig werden ohne enkel sind die
aufgeschmissen die hotlines sind
überlastet was läuft in dieser ganzen
logistik eigentlich falsch das regt die
leute ja mindestens genauso auf wie die
frage wann kommt mein impfstoff deshalb
möglicherweise sogar da ist der
impfstoff ich komm bloß nicht an ihn an
also ich glaube die imf logistik war
noch der grössere aufreger als die
impfstoff beschaffungs geschichte denn
wir haben ja wirklich ganz grausame 10
bei uns im bürgertelefon erlebt und
aktuell haben natürlich die situation
dass termine bis einschließlich ende
april vergeben sind weil man natürlich
dass auch vorsichtig sagt wir können nur
termine vorgeben wo auch im stoff für
sicher ist aber natürlich viele jetzt
noch keinen termin haben so dass so ein
bisschen der eindruck entsteht da waren
hatten war eine lotterie und die die
glücklich sind die sind jetzt
durchgekommen und die anderen die sind
jetzt im ersten flotte hinten
runtergefallen
das wird natürlich die diskussion auch
die stimmung in der bevölkerung belasten
das muss man denke ich auch noch
aufarbeiten und da muss man natürlich
auch insgesamt denke ich mal der
bevölkerung dann keinen wein einschenken
und sagen leute das ist suboptimal
gelaufen wir hätten uns als kommunale
seite da bin ich mit den
landratskollegen passieren noch zum
westfalen ein ich gerne gehabt dass wir
nicht nur in die aufstellung von
impfzentren eingebunden sind sondern
auch gerade in das organisieren der impf
terminvergabe
das hätten wir dann kreis für kreis
kreisfreie stadt für kreisfreie stadt
meinetwegen auch mit der kv zusammen
glaub ich besser hingekriegt denn wir
haben ja auch mal die softwarelösungen
analysiert wir haben auch mal das was
dann in telefonhotlines alles schief
gelaufen ist da könnte ich jetzt ganze
scheck und kassenärztlicher vereinigung
da auch glaube das hat die leute echt
auch die barrikaden getrieben
und da müssen wir wirklich alle
gemeinsam für verloren gegangenes
vertrauen sorgen und wiederherstellen da
gibt es eine ganze reihe von
organisationen auch die kassenärztliche
vereinigung wurster probleme gab
herr kaiser vielleicht in dem
zusammenhang noch die kanzlerin hat ja
gestern noch mal gesagt sie geht da
lieber auf nummer sicher sie war
oder ist gegen diese sogenannten notfall
zulassungen es war auch wichtig dass man
lange über die haftungsfragen diskutiert
und verhandelt hat mit der
pharmaindustrie war das richtig diese
sicherheit vor schnelligkeit zu
praktizieren
ich glaube man muss abwägen das ist eine
neue krankheit dass die neue impfstoffe
wir lernen daran auch wir ärzte kannten
ja diese krankheit nicht man muss da
tatsächlich abwägen und dann entscheiden
wenn entschieden werden muss aber jetzt
generell zu sagen
die impfstoffe sind noch nicht richtig
evaluiert das geht nicht es ist ein
erwartungsdruck da andererseits kann man
nicht warten bis die einzelnen phasen
hintereinander abgeschlossen sind dann
dauert jahre
man muss da von fall zu fall entscheiden
man muss auch tatsächlich verschiedene
impfstoffe nehmen
aber wir wissen ja noch gar nicht wie es
ausgeht vielleicht stellt sich raus dass
irgendwann die mutation oder der
impfstoff aber nicht hilft bei der
rotation aber der impfstoff cd der hilft
also das wissen wir alles noch gar nicht
insofern ist das eine ganz schwierige
sache und man muss einfach zugeben dass
man die erfahrung ist braucht wir werden
hinterher schlauer sein aber das nützt
uns nichts
im großen und ganzen muss sich einfach
sagen es ist relativ gut gelaufen auch
ich könnte eine liste aufstellen was
schief gelaufen ist natürlich ist die
116 117 überlassen natürlich haben die
mobilen teams auch manchmal blödsinn
gemacht die haben bei mir im heim der
sterbende patientin noch geimpft mit 95
jahren die sowieso im sterbeprozess war
weil sie die auflage hatten alle im heim
zu impfen
die konnte nun nicht mehr widersprechen
das sind alles einzelschicksale die man
aber nicht jetzt zum hammer voranstellen
kann ich selber bin selbst im
rentenalter und noch gar nicht an
impfstoff angekommen während die 20
jährigen studentin in dem impfzentrum
helfen die nur die patienten von a nach
b schieben die sind alle durch geimpft
ist auch gesagt worden dass impfstoff
weggeworfen wurde im impfzentrum wenn
der übrig geblieben ist und das ist sie
es sie dürfen ihn nicht bekommen wir
haben es nicht
also die vorgaben sind anders das sind
alles einzelfälle
und das darf man nicht voran stellen in
der tat ist es im großen und ganzen
relativ gut gelaufen und ich habe auch
im vertrauen in die pharmazeutische
industrie in diesem fall
ich denke ja nur freie marktwirtschaft
ist immer noch besser als eine
planwirtschaft das hat die vergangenheit
gezeigt da kann ich was zu sagen dass
sie jetzt dank der medien zu gehen ja
viele informationen und unter anderem
eine information dass er die impfstoffe
unterschiedlich wirksam sind ja die
haben einen wirkungsgrad in prozent
ausgedrückt ist das ist ein problem für
die vermittlung von impfstoffen auch die
frage welcher impfstoff das ist mir ja
noch gar nicht genau
mutationen abfängt und welcher nach
entwickelt werden muss dass diese auf
ganz unterschiedlichen ebenen im moment
diese wirksamkeits diskussion läuft
diese wirtschaftskreis diskussion die
müssen wir zur kenntnis nehmen und
sicherlich kann vielleicht sogar ein
mediziner diese frage noch besser
beantworten als ein pharmazeut
wir wissen heute aufgrund der klinischen
studien die die verschiedenen firmen ja
durchführen dass es ein
unterschiedliches wird profil gibt das
ist richtig was sie sagen wir wissen
auch von einigen studien dass sie
beispielsweise unterschiedlichen grad
der verhinderung in der schwere der chor
ohne erkrankung haben wir wissen aber
vor allen dingen und das ist wichtig
dass jeder zugelassene impfstoff der in
europa zur anwendung kommt eine sehr
hohe wirkung hat die mindestens über dem
eines üblichen grippe impfstoffes legten
das ist eine sehr positive botschaft ich
möchte noch ein satz sagen zu der frage
die sie herrn kollegenkreis gestellt
haben
300 millionen beschaffung wäre mehr
notwendig gewesen oder besser gewesen
ich persönlich denke folgendes man hat
bei der beschaffung etwas auf der
europäischen ebene sehr richtig gemacht
indem man auf sehr viele pferde gesetzt
hat man hat mit sehr vielen unternehmen
verträge abgeschlossen und wir sehen
jetzt wie klug das gewesen ist weil
einige firmen bedauerlicherweise nicht
so schnell wie andere zum impfstoff
gekommen
ich würde mir das manchmal wünschen dass
dieses modell der beschaffung
beispielsweise auch bei der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung bei den
rabattverträgen greift mein kollege
hausarzt wird das bestätigen können weil
wir würden damit ähnliche probleme oder
vor allem die lieferprobleme darf
vermeiden können also für mich taucht
dieses modell durch als blaupause für
künftige gesundheitspolitik in
deutschland als diskussionsthema ist
liegt woanders aber dann haben wir
übrigens im auge dadurch dass jetzt ein
impfstoff zum beispiel nicht an über 65
jährige ebenfalls in deutschland nach
der entlassung verimpft wird kommt jetzt
die diskussion auch sollen ja auch
können dann mit jüngere dann auch
geimpft werden oder 65 nach der
priorisierung dass zwei möglicherweise
so ganz nach dem nachdem alltags prinzip
nicht richtig wird uns diese diskussion
jetzt richtig ins haus stehen
wahrscheinlich muss man schon darüber
diskutieren was man jetzt mit den dosen
macht die man zur verfügung hat jetzt an
bestimmte gruppen nicht verimpft werden
können also dass das ziel das man im
auge haben muss ist natürlich zuerst
besonders schutzbedürftigen zu schützen
aber immer auch möglichst der
herdenimmunität in deutschland zu
erreichen oder als ich in die richtung
zu bewegen um lockerungen auch wieder
möglich zu machen dass kinder wieder zur
schule gehen können und in die kita von
da her da muss man natürlich davon ab
stürzt abstand nehmen
wie sehen sie das mit der priorisierung
ist das so wie es jetzt geregelt es im
wesentlichen in ordnung oder ist der
reformbedarf
also es ist natürlich der besserung
möglichkeit an allen ecken und enden ist
zu 98 prozent läuft das gut die zwei
prozent die schief laufen die werden wir
versuchen zu verbessern
ich will nur noch eine sache sagen zu
diesem impfstoff der nur für die unter
65-jährigen verimpft werden soll in
zukunft genau dieser impfstoff wird in
einem anderen land was vielleicht über
uns lacht gerade die älteren gegeben so
warum geben wir den nicht den älteren
aus folgendem grund bei der überprüfung
dabei der studie dieses impfstoffs war
die gruppe der über 65 jährigen an
auch sehr klein und deshalb da die daten
nicht sicher aber der wird natürlich
auch bei den älteren patienten und
wahrscheinlich wird man den auch die
zulassung erweitern aber das ist jetzt
mit prognose die ist sogar diese studie
gruppe sich erweitert der menschen statt
65 nämlich an werden auch sicher alle
gruppen dulden können also so werden
diese studiengruppe dann auch über 65
entsprechende ergebnisse nicht wenn man
glaubt gar nicht wie schnell 44 minuten
und 30 sekunden vorbei gehen ich bedanke
mich dass sie hier waren bei anna
sauerbrey bahn hans-georg feldmeier bei
wolfgang reicher und bei stephan pusch
ob sie jetzt eine impfstoff misere ist
oder nicht weil es nur den zuschauern
gerade sitzen die meinung bilden können
vielen dank die wir zuschauer morgen in
der phoenix runde regieren gegen das
virus die groko in corona war ja da geht
es dann um die politischen akzente des
themas es folgt phoenix der tag mit
constantia bretzke darin angela merkel
dieses mal zur aktuellen situation um
den nav allen die prozess in moskau
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]